[Musique]
bien jean chalencon son nom vous dit
certainement quelque chose si vous êtes
fan de vieilles affaires tard de
l'émission affaires conclues sur france
2 durant des années
le chroniqueur collectionneurs avaient
soudainement quitté l'émission l'année
passée affaire conclue
la raison une énorme polémique qui avait
éclaté lors de la diffusion sur internet
d'une photo de lui aux côtés du très
controversé dieudonné
d'autant que cette photo aurait été
prise lors d'un anniversaire de jean
marie le pen est là encore un homme qui
divisent sur les réseaux le
collectionneur s'était défendu d'être un
ami de dieudonné
je reconnais que c'était une faute mais
tous ceux qui me connaissent savent que
je ne peux pas être soupçonné de
partager les idées de dieu donne est
accusé d'être antisémite il avait
ensuite tenté de se justifier chez
morandini chez mais j'ose à la maison à
mea culpa qui n'a visiblement pas suffi
à france 2 qui a décidé quelques
semaines plus tard de se séparer de son
expert sophie davant animatrice de
l'émission avait expliqué il sait pas
c'est qu'il a un petit peu trop parlé
sur les réseaux sociaux et qu'on lui a
dit à plusieurs reprises de faire
attention
alors faut-il pardonner pierre-jean
chalencon ce soir élite avec nous pour
revenir sur cette polémique et tout nous
dire sur les véritables raisons de ce
départ merci père jean chalencon d'être
avec nous ce soir et c'est vrai que
cette histoire nous a peiné elle nous a
peiné parce que on vous aimez beaucoup
et on se dit voilà et c'est vrai qu'on
vous avait été présenté comme un monstre
alors j'aimerais qu'on revienne sur
plusieurs choses pires gens parce que
serré car plein de gens les bleus public
et aux îles vierges en chalencon c'était
la figure emblématique doit faire
d'affaires conclut c'est vrai voilà
alors j'adore les autres si ils sont
très sympas mais pierre blanc c'était la
figure numéro une d'affaires conclut
alors on va voir justement vos frasques
dans affaire conclue et après pierre jo
on voudrait votre témoignage
on va vous poser toutes les questions
même des questions qui dérangent et un
bien sûr et justes dans le dans le
magnéto ils étaient chez morandini shana
on a un prénom jean marc et moi non mais
c'est bon quoi bon là j'ai l'impression
d'être en classe qu'on fait la paix là
haut c'est parti on va travailler
[Musique]
2 qu'est ce que l'on te sourit bonjour
j'adore le sport pratiqué sur les belles
et comme vale comme nous et comme bell
bell alors vous pourrez poser toutes les
questions ou la pierre jean chalencon il
va y répondre
pierre-jean déjà première chose oui dans
quel état vous êtes aujourd'hui je suis
en super forme d'accord vous avez été
très attristée par tout ce qui s'est
passé je sais que ça a été horrible
tu sais c'est à dire quoi toujours au
lendemain du jour au lendemain tu étais
très haut il y en a un certain nombre
autour de la table côté comme moi tu es
très haut puis tu te retrouves très bas
et surtout quand c'est pas justifier
quoi ce que si on dit que je suis
antisémite
enfin faut arrêter quoi je suis le mec
le plus cool et le plus proche de la
communauté ou non mais au-delà de ça
antisémites racistes le pen machin
vraiment horrible gilles verdez oui mais
moi je vous apprécie humainement vous le
savez mais franchement vous devenez
sulfureux aller à l'anniversaire de jean
marie le pen faire une photo avec
dieudonné dieudonné c'est quelqu'un qui
n'est pas fréquentable c'est quelqu'un
que tu es été condamné vous ne pouvez
pas faire ça et ça ça m'a profondément
choqué lui a entièrement raison et j'ai
fait une erreur qui est jeu
voilà c'est j'ai vraiment fait une
erreur mais tu sais ça faisait trois
mois que j'étais confiné j'avais sous
projets d'émissions de télévision avec
catherine barma pas les millièmes
productrice et voilà je vais j'ai
rencontré robert hue j'ai rencontré
brigitte macron parents j'ai rencontré
plein de gens c'est donc dans l'année et
donc me propose d'aller vers ça de le
bungee c'est super on va enfin pouvoir
des gens et je vais rester dix minutes
j'ai vraiment pas vu c'est pas notre
quand même baissé mais j'ai fait je n'y
retournerai plus non mais c'est pas non
plus la soirée de l'année et honnêtement
moi jai ho on se connaît moi j'ai vu un
peu c'est vrai que moi je moi j'ai un
regard nouvelle jean marie le pen mais
c'était pour rien mais qui souhaitent
aller fouiller votre copain diaye de
dire super longtemps et voilà assumer
assumer la vous êtes là bas on comprend
pas jean anglade il ya une ambiance si
jean marie le pen on m'appelle on dit à
une grosse soirée chez jean marie le pen
comme ça t'es pas de quoi émerveiller
toi à bordel 5le fayard les dinosaures
je me suis dit c'est pas faut rencontrer
c'est quand même intéressant non mais
qu'est-ce que wright et foot à soigner à
faire comment tu as fait trop mais
anniversaire de jean marie le pen
s'apprête à vis des écoutes
ça a duré 10 minutes et puis sur sûr
partie d'ailleurs et après l'invitation
aucun doute été incrustés non ma fille
tu es oui qu'est-ce qui m'a invité et
ben c'est le pen parce que le pen a
regardé l'émission l'émission affaire
conclue
guérison quoi ben écoute j'aime beaucoup
de choses à acheter chez lui d'ailleurs
les normes et donc et donc et appelle
celui que tu appelles non non non c'est
samedi 6 à la fois mais c'est vrai
qu'est-ce que vous allez [ __ ] cette
année dernière j'ai fait une connerie
j'aurais pas dû j'aurais dû accepter
d'aller chez line renaud ç'aurait été
plus drôle c'est clair donc et à moi
j'ai franchement on se connaît depuis un
moment je vous ai vu venir sur le
plateau et j'ai des sentiments et on est
franchement je penses tu pas le seul que
il ya eut abandonné d'un bouton mode
carrière
à mon avis ça s'est un peu échauffés et
franchement et je voudrais payer ça et
je vais bien payés parce qu'à un moment
c'est gentil mais la vérité c'est vrai
que à un moment tu es invité partout
quoi
bien sûr le même avion marie le pen non
mais tu déjeunes à l'elysée avec qui tu
sais tu avec titus et le maquereau
- tu lui dis à lui on dirait que c'est
lui qui préside aussi bon tu invites à
cédric villani qui bien bouffer tutu
chantent la marseillaise avec nicolas
sarkozy
bon bah c'est vrai qu'en l'espace d'un
an tu aurais pu ré attention c'est pas
la même bien tu vas au super u avec nec
ok c'est de se dire qu'elle nous avait
pété un câble vous vous sentiez
intouchable touchable mais je pensais
que je pensais que je pouvais faire des
shows viable on le voit votre tenue
maintenant vous travaillez chez darty
[Rires]
j'ai des écrans vidéo très bien
d'ailleurs ma soeur tu mens mais deux
frérots alors on comptera six ans pour
autant ok très bien là on rigole et tout
mais en même temps il ya un moment non
seulement vous vous sentiez peut-être
intouchable et vous aviez un peu pété le
boulard mais vous attaquiez et on
comprenait pas pourquoi vous avez viande
et les autres vous avez un bon
encadrement
oui il avait atteint vous qui les a
mérités j'étais moi je dis tout ici j'en
ai à la casse et les pires si nous avons
déjà cassé les pieds et bien les choses
l'argent parce que voilà je te dis les
choses je préfère parce que quand on est
quelqu'un qu'on connaît au moins
quelqu'un sait l'importance et la même
rapporté qu'il avait mal parlé de moi
dans une conférence et on m'a même
envoyé le sonore je te le dis il a voulu
faire le malin
c'est un moment je vais pas dire qu'il
ya un moment tu part en cacahuète très
sincère et tu es ont même tenté pas
préparé à ça
ouais moi au départ la télévision j'en
ai jamais fait mais alors un petit oui
oui madame je disais et d'adaptation
unanime
attention ça c'est la famille mais n'ont
pas peur si je disais vous disais oui ça
m'est montée à la tête voilà je suis
devenu un peu ingérable j'étais tout
fouet et voilà mais en revanche ça ne
vous auto en fin même même même si vous
étiez devenu complètement dingue et avec
un melon démesurée pourquoi vous avoir
eu envie de vous attaquer à line renaud
pourquoi à thomas à votre même à votre
concert comment il s'appelait calais
margerie dons
les bazookas quoi oui bien sûr mais
après ma les rodos une des histoires bon
voilà d'ailleurs même isabelle mergault
siemens est très bien le club va devenir
de plus en plus important mais c'est une
femme que je respecte un bien sûr mais
bon elle est pas si gentil que ça et
puis bon ben alors l'avenir le dira mais
c'est pas très grave je n'en veux pas
moi j'adore une rue où vous savez j'ai
aidé beaucoup pour le sida j'ai
énormément participé à au sidaction il
ya très longtemps à l'époque en janvier
chez gaston lenôtre avec plein de plein
d'amis et puis bon ben je suis quand
même très touché par cette cause et en
france parce que faisant partie de la
communauté
après on peut s'attaquer à des gens ça a
été ça a été un moment j'ai cassé j'ai
pété un câble et je pense que
malheureusement d'ailleurs ça m'a fait
du bien d'ailleurs cessé c'est plus de
six mois un miroir inde en tête de cette
histoire où je me suis fait une zen
d'ailleurs je suis parti un mois en
corse c'est pour te dire je suis allé
voir napoléon alors nicolas père du
projet juste que j'aimerais c'est ce que
j'aimerais savoir vous comprenez quand
même que maintenant vous êtes devenu un
personnage et non par exemple pour
france télévisions c'est à dire que
france télévisions va pas vous appeler
demain matin vous avez quand même cassé
tout le monde vous avez vous étiez
effectivement c'est l'accumulation le
pen serré cumulation en fait vous avez
cassé et line renaud vous avez cassé
clara morgane nous avait quatre c'est
d'als vous avez cassé des fins vous avez
cassé nabila sur le sac sais pas
pourquoi vous faites ça c'est là encore
vous allez faire rire même série la leaf
un tweet ensuite vous avez dit que
hanouna était un manipulateur c'est ce
que j'ai retenu dans la presse locale a
rebondi ce que je comprends pas moi
c'est c'est que vous cherchez quoi vous
pensiez pas ce que c'est c'est au delà
d'un touchable c'est à dire que à un
moment donné on vous a lancé des alertes
ouais dire que même moi la tête et je
vous ai dit pour vous protéger puisqu'on
a communiqué derrière je dis je calmez
vous arrêter parce qu'à un moment donné
vous êtes président de france
télévisions vous êtes patron d'unités
vous ne pouvez pas avoir un mec comme ça
que tu es ce bal année qui crachent sur
tout le monde et après line renaud vous
pouvez avoir imprimé avec des grelots
mais il faut vraiment être con pour cet
accueil diderot moi je connais titre
personnel et que j'aime beaucoup mais
pourquoi allez-vous vous attaquer tout
le temps à des gens qui potentiellement
bémol mauvais roman g de noix ou à
n'importe quel moment
oui la mégane pas la mégane alors oui il
a le droit de faire des erreurs c'est un
personnage de télé il est excentrique
c'est pour ça qu'on aime c'est pour ça
que les gens l'aiment bonjour parce
qu'il a fait une pose photo ec dieudonné
on connaît même pas le prix mais ça
m'étonnerait pour la vraie question
juste mon bateau mais on connaît on
connaît pas les contextes des histoires
et c'est tout le monde s'est déjà fait
avoir enfin plein de célébrités avec des
photos avec des personnes etc
je trouve ça extrêmement forte et où la
moindre erreur était déjà sur une
branche d'arbre cahier l'ajustant
derrière moi est avec lui donner jean
marie le pen est bien foutu position b
le mec derrière d'ailleurs politique
actuelle elle est brisée d'accord il
n'est pas juste en train de se faire
défoncer sur un plateau déjà ce qui est
désagréable pour lui il sa carrière elle
est brisée tu trouves que c'est juste de
briser la carrière de quelqu'un pour des
tweeté une photo c'est dégueulasse alors
attendez c'est de garder les trois
hommes edel c'est de garrigae poursuivi
mais je le condamne aussi je le condamne
aussi et je hais la question c'est est
ce que les mois je pense qu'il manque
aux téléspectateurs il manque l émission
un vrai personnage de télé et est ce que
les gens lui en veulent un vrai produit
aujourd'hui france télévisions et
chaussées et puis je suis père jean
aujourd'hui france télécom possible en
moi parce que il est presque chaque fois
près de pierre-jean on va penser à cette
photo qui est derrière vous mais moi
j'ai sonné marie le pen méthode et
surtout là que jeune homme il ya une
accusation que tu veux faire
il savait pas que à gérer moi je ne
pouvais pas cracher dans la main qui
vous fait manger d'accord qui s'attaque
en permanence à la télé chaque fois
qu'ils perdent huit ans la main syrie
lui a tendu la main à un moment donné je
suis pas en train de vous allumer un
cierge en chantant s'essayer cimade au
s2 au cassis non pas du tout mais
derrière il est à s'exprimer derrière
avait aussi sur les réseaux sociaux mais
je vous donne un exemple série lui a
tendu la main à un moment donné pourquoi
ils commencent avait craché sur cyril
s'est jamais approché sûr s'il a droit
de faire si on regarde ma montre et il
fait manipuler par cyril donc à un
moment donné syrie est sympa de nous
inviter on est tous sympas nous allons
c'est pourquoi vous faites ce genre de
conneries c'est s'était tue on s'en
rappelle c'était pas dans cette émission
c'était danse avec les stars est
d'ailleurs france 2 n'aurait jamais
accepté que je fasse ce doit s'adapter
star puisque ça rappelle toi quand je
devais faire cette fameuse série qu'on
devait faire historique ensemble ils ont
appelé quelques jours avant qu'on
commence
et pour te dire que j'étais personnage
de france télévisions que c'était pas
possible qu'on fasse cette petite
séquence historique
donc ça c'est sympa après gier on peut
tous faire des erreurs moi vous savez je
suis loin d'être le roi du twitter
exceptionnement bourget la pression
pierre jean teulère été moi j'ai
l'impression que tu te chauffe très vite
je me suis très vite et amazon com sur
la nasa montrent comme ça et je
redescendrai y aller lentement et après
moi j'ai zappé et j'oublie ça et tu
oublies disons mais sauf que les écrits
les photos ça reste derrière tu payes
ton très exactement ce que je suis bien
sûr que d'aujourd'hui quand tu quand il
ya des gens qui tu accuses de de raciste
oui qui disent que qui est dit ce que
voit la tête et était antisémite et
raciste
qu'est ce que tu leur réponds bah je dis
c'est là c'est totalement n'importe quoi
est ce que cette peine
wissam peine parce que si un mec est le
plus proche de la communauté c'est bien
moi j'ai encore faim et encore 15 jours
un mariage à la maison pour des amis de
la communauté
j'ai une synagogue au dessus de la
maison je suis à gia lai châu quand on
veut tuer son chien on dit qu'il a la
rage
donc c'est très facile de dire ça après
en attendant je vais dire un truc à
faire conclut c'est quand même une
émission france télévisions était très
au courant de qui était à danser dans
cette émission
j'en suis quand même vous l'avez tous
dit à des éléments moteurs à l'époque et
en attendant depuis je suis parti il ya
eu des best-of tout l'hiver et qui avait
qui avait c'était votre site votre
serviteur a été mis en best of best of
qui sont faits depuis ces dernières
donc elle après mon départ donc je
manque très bien cassano a certainement
sa démission même sophie davant le dit
sur ce que disait guillaume on fait tous
des erreurs faites vous n'êtes pas là
mais une photo celle fille comme ça et
dieudonné lala non mais là c'est pas une
erreur dans la rue c'est une photo
regarde posé presque concertée et moi je
voulais dit quand je les ai vus
honnêtement j'ai été mais parce que je
vous aime bien j'ai été plus que choqué
et je me suis dit que c'était de
militantisme politique et belgique
oui mais j'ai cui mis d'accord en moi
d'accord mais j'ai compris j'ai compris
les accusations dont je peux comprendre
que ça mais ça avec dans des photos ont
fait mal d'objets mais juste prix argent
à un moment donné quand il ya dieudonné
avait été dévoué qui auront fait la
faute au sénat elle est posée en train
oui plus en outre at on dit jamais mais
qu'est ce que je fous là mais
honnêtement part que je me suis dit ils
veulent être traités de temps de partir
mais on attend j'ai pas réalisé le mal
du truc franchement honnêtement je n'ai
pas vu au mal enfin dieu tu sais moi je
fais 50 photos par jour
et d'ailleurs vous vous êtes vous avez
tous raison de dire ça mais depuis ça
fait quand même sept ou huit mois cette
photo j'ai été moi j'ai voyagé en france
celle en belgique je suis partout tout
le monde s'en fout de cette photo tout
le monde s'en branle
bien que le parisianisme et quelques
personnalités de france où je ne sais où
ils se disputent un il a fait une photo
avec mes verres mais j'en fais plein des
photos vous croyez quand j'ai fait des
j'étais encore cet été là j'ai descendu
les champs elysées la semaine derrière
il y avait tous les éboueurs qui étaient
là ouais chalencon à faire conclut
machin je suis populaire je suivrai quoi
qu'on veuille aujourd'hui je suis
populaire et je suis là ben alors
maintenant il faudra faire avec moi si
on va plus le même mec qui a six mois
voilà c'est pas parce que tu as prénom
en verlan tu peux te la péter
face à l'apathie et je voudrais une des
votes dernier mot aux téléspectateurs
qui ont voilà qui ont eu tout ça c'est
parti d'un homme vierge en question à
dire aux téléspectateurs qui c'est à
dire aux personnes qui nous regardent ce
soit eh bien écoutez en tout cas vous me
manquer énormément je vous aime
considérablement merci pour toutes ces
preuves d'amour vous avez envoyé que
vous m'envoyez quotidiennement en
voulait à france télé non pas du tout
j'en veux à bessans veux à personne
moi je suis le mec que vous ayez comme
saluerait j'ai là il va s'entraîner seul
air france ce sens qu'est ce que tu veux
jouer c'est fait c'est fait il faut
aller de l'avant moi je suis un mec qui
va de l'avant
j'ai plein de projets j'aime à poser à
travers olivier lejeune j'ai mon
spectacle sur brassens avec fred karato
j'ai les projets avec stéphane joffre
ce qu'on aime voila voila j'ai plein de
projets en attendant france 2 ont versé
pour revenir à la télé sexy toujours
évidemment il peut revenir sur qui peut
revenir mais il faut qu'il arrête parce
que ya encore quelques jours il fait un
tweet sur la ville a par exemple sur le
sac de nabila est ce que vous avez
vraiment besoin de faire ça c'est soit
tu sais pourquoi ça m'a fait ça reste un
sac à 65000 euros
aujourd'hui des étudiants et les gens
qui viennent y fut un temps évoqué des
assurés moi c'est parce ogier qui pointe
de l'empiré
vous allez encore vous excuser alors
nabila à chaque fois non et vous lui
faites un truc est derrière vous excusez
moi je vous avez un gros merci à bastia
et la cie pire les jours mon chéri et
pierre chante tu sais pourquoi on fait
ça parce qu'on comptait mais on a été
déçus
donc voila merci à toi de m'avoir invité
parce que tu es un ami et je t'aime très
fort et cheklam a déçu ce que j'ai vu
voilà et la prochaine fois papa va
passer anniversaire j'irai quotidien
chez benhaim elle fait des boulettes
magnifique